I think mr. Matt is the worst single
worst yeah it looks like a botched
experiment is it looks like something
that you it looks like it's saying
please yeah
[Music]
[Music]
noting those homers over the
do you have hey hey holy mackerel the
Cub song no doubt about it
it's pretty bad this is the song of the
played for years where they just to
where they just wallow din they were
still singing this song no doubt about
it the Cubs are gonna blow
alright well get this together there's a
Red Sox song that's awful it was really
yeah yeah and it had a banjo it's all
banjo I think there was one that live
like that like
[Music]
Wow yeah we white people have got it
good and we're always gonna have it good
I want to have that have KY yes dunsky
put on my horn of my car go down the 405
someone's crowd me a little bit what I
wouldn't give to have that oh you could
get that done I could get that done
hello Tesla I know I'm like the 50th
today thank you thank you Ilan iran's
the best update what can be to come out
the back only 40,000 sure thing come on
a brian took his own life today after
ordering corn chowder to come out the
back of his tesla coroner says his
glasses were on in a comical fashion but
that that did not contribute to his
death
[Music]
you